kyle rittenhouse's trial goes completely
sideways for the prosecution media
respond by attacking the written house
judge and bite inflation is here and
it's massive i'm benchmare this is the
bench bureau
[Music]
show men shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first using the internet
without expressvpn really bad idea it's
like your drive up to a gas station you
leave your keys in the ignition you go
inside to buy a drink well you should
have taken your keys because now there's
that guy who's just going down the
street in your car well you don't want
to do that with your data okay your data
is your business don't leave it wide
open for anyone to steal every time you
connect to an unencrypted network cafes
hotels airports any hacker on the same
network can gain access to your personal
data it doesn't take much technical
knowledge to hack somebody pretty much
anybody could do it and your data is
valuable because hackers can make up to
a thousand dollars per person selling
personal information on the dark web so
why use expressvpn it creates an
encrypted tunnel that secures your
device right essentially that tunnel is
between your device and the internet so
hackers can't steal your sensitive data
it's very very secure it's easy to use
with one click you download it with
another click it is now running on your
device i've been using expressvpn for
years it's what makes me feel safe and
secure about my data you should feel the
same way secure your online data today
by visiting expressvpn.com
ben that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com you get an extra
three months for free expressvpn
then go check it out right now okay so i
just want to remind you before we go
through the details of the britton house
trial which has just gone completely
sideways for the prosecution it's a
complete fail for the prosecution and
honestly has created significant issues
for me with institutional trust i think
the last couple of years in particular
have demonstrated that all of the
institutional distrust that frankly
drove donald trump to the presidency
was well-founded it is it is deeply
disturbing when you see that
institutions that you are supposed to
trust
have been lying to you are manipulatable
are not honest they don't do their
fundamental job and when you see trials
like the written house trial
you think to yourself okay i'm not sure
how i'm supposed to trust that the
system is apolitical
and we've seen this in nearly every area
of american life we've seen
bureaucracies that are designed to
protect you at your workplace now being
used to ram down vaccine mandates on 85
million americans we've seen cdc
a
system that is supposed to prevent the
spread of disease telling homeowners
that they're not allowed to evict
renters
we we've had bureaucracies that have
been completely twisted into what they
were not supposed to be the fbi and the
doj basically using clinton oppo dump
research in order to initiate
investigations on allies of president
trump and then spend four years
essentially propping up an investigation
predicated on false
nonsense that was propagated by the
clinton team
you know we've seen so many institutions
in american life they've completely
blown all credibility
what we're now watching as the
supposedly independent federal reserve
takes its orders from the biden
administration
we're watching as the media which was
supposed to be the arbiter of truth
becomes essentially just a democratic
left-wing talking points propaganda
machine
we've watched as facebook and google and
all of our social media tech companies
the big tech companies are batted about
by the state so much that they
essentially just become propagators of
democratic party propaganda attempting
to scuttle any outlet that doesn't
mirror those positions
all of this is super disturbing for
people and the written house trial is
just one of those moments when the truth
bobs its head above the waves and you
say oh there's probably an iceberg under
there there's definitely an iceberg
under there so i just want to go for a
walk down memory lane grabian put out a
supercut of all of the various pundits
and commentators who had things to say
about kyle rittenhouse and the immediate
aftermath of what happened in kenosha
wisconsin
last year you'll recall the kenosha
wisconsin was set on fire over jacob
blake after the media promulgated a lie
which is that the police shot an unarmed
man for no good reason it was not true
about jacob blake jacob blake was a
criminal and jacob blake was carrying a
knife and the police shot jacob lake
because he refused to put down the knife
after they ordered him a million times
to put down the knife and all of it was
on tape and the media ran with the false
narrative anyway and kenosha burned and
then kyle rittenhouse
who apparently knew the the people who
were attempting to guard a car
dealership decided that he was going to
go 20 minutes down the road and he was
going to help protect the car dealership
he's going to wipe away graffiti he was
going to do some medical treatment on
people who are who are injured in in the
riots that were happening and then he
got roped into a horrible situation in
which he had to shoot three people
and all of that was on tape the
shootings were on tape and we could see
from the get-go what happened and
barring some sort of extraneous evidence
that showed the contrary and i always
wait on these cases i really do i try to
be considered about jumping in in the
early moments of cases and giving you
sort of preliminary thoughts without all
of the evidence being available because
sometimes you get more evidence that
wasn't available i'd rather be late than
be first and wrong late and write is
better than first and wrong okay but
everybody in the media is incentivized
to give an opinion on cases right from
the get-go
and without any provisos and so the
media in the face of the available
evidence suggested the written house
went there as a white supremacist to
murder people here's a supercut from
gravian people making the suggestion
beginning with jason johnson over at
msnbc
ridden house is basically what you would
have had in a school shooter he's a 17
year old kid he shouldn't have had a gun
he crossed state lines to supposedly
protect property no he was going out to
shoot people kyle rittenhouse the 17
year old vigilante kyle rittenhouse the
vigilante kyle rittenhouse the armed
teenage vigilante a 17 year old
vigilante
arguably a domestic terrorist picked up
a rifle drove to a different state to
shoot people kyle rittenhouse
a guy who's deeply racist went with
weapons to a black lives matter protest
looking to get in trouble he did he
murdered a couple of people rittenhouse
uh the 17 year old kid
just running around
shooting and killing protesters you see
the 17 year old who was radicalized by
trumpism took his ar-15 to kenosha and
became a killer
okay so um kyle rittenhouse is going to
be a very very rich man if the jury does
what it obviously has to do in this case
and quits him because kyle written how
should have all she should have his
lawyers on speed dial
this makes covington catholic look like
nothing covington catholic was about the
humiliation of a bunch of school kids
for doing nothing but standing there you
have
commentators on these networks with the
tape available calling him a domestic
terrorist and a white supremacist these
are prominent people there's people like
chank wieger and steve schmidt of the
lincoln project which has a habit of
going after minors
john heilemann talking about his
domestic terrorist
joe scarborough suggesting that he's
running around shooting and killing
protesters
you're not a protester once you go for
somebody's gun guys that ain't how that
works
and you'll remember that facebook
legitimately banned links to
rittenhouse's defense fund we had his
lawyer on before the before the trial
began
and his legal team was saying they could
not raise funds they couldn't crowdfund
so you could have kamala harris bailing
out rioters in the middle of the 2020
blm riots but kyle rittenhouse could not
raise a defense fund because the big
tech companies essentially labeled him a
domestic terrorist they labeled him
somebody who was not worthy of being
able to raise money for his legal
defense
the blaze reported that just last year
facebook has banned users from sharing a
crowdfunding link to assist with the
legal fees for 17 year old kyle
rittenhouse who was charged with
homicide last week following fatal
shootings that occurred during a riot in
kenosha but the site allows posts asking
for fundraising for several other
individuals who have been charged with
crimes including murder
and like so they basically singled out
rittenhouse
the washington times reported online
fundraisers were made for the teen's
legal defense shortly after he was
identified as the suspect but they
quickly vanished from gofundme
gofundme said that campaigns for written
house violated its terms of service but
did not explain any further
facebook did allow links for other
fundraisers including mark wilson a 21
year old who's charged with felony
murder after killing a 17 year old girl
there was a gofundme started by michael
moore to support individuals prosecuted
for tearing down monuments
there's a minnesota freedom fund
promoted by a commonwealth heritage all
of these people were able to raise money
not kyle rittenhouse because cal
rittenhouse was pre-judged by the media
to be a domestic terrorist guilty white
supremacist
and none of it ended up being true
none of it
okay this case never should have been
brought again my faith in the system is
such that i figured if they're bringing
a case maybe they know something i don't
because that does happen in trial
sometimes sometimes they bring a case
and then the case ends up being stronger
than you thought it was going to be or
sometimes they bring a case and it ends
up being weaker than you thought it was
going to be and you don't know until the
evidence is in the room
and so i tend to withhold judgment in
these cases until the evidence is in the
room
okay but when you see a case this bad
being brought this horrible being
brought you got to think the institution
has now been gutted from the inside when
prosecutors are bringing cases
specifically because of political
pressure
you cannot feel safe
i'm talking about you you cannot feel
safe in a system where prosecutors are
bringing cases purely out of political
pressure
if you happen to be on the wrong side of
the media in any particular conflict
you will end up in the prosecutor's
crosshairs and it undermines my faith in
the system when it comes to everything
from the blm rioters most of whom were
basically let off scot-free
to the sentencing of people on january
6th again i think criminals should go to
jail if you commit a crime you should go
to jail
but now i want to see all the evidence
in all these cases
because
i gotta say when you again when you see
a little bit of the iceberg above the
water line you start to think oh maybe
these institutions maybe maybe there's
that iceberg is a real and i don't want
to rip on the institutions i'm a
conservative i think the institutions
are necessary and good but only if they
follow due process of law
and prosecutorial discretion is part of
due process of law and that
prosecutorial discretion
is supposed to be independent and not
shaped by media pressure
okay in one second we'll get to the
actual testimony yesterday because kyle
rittenhouse took the stand which is a
unique and rare move in a defense of a
murder trial
first let's talk about a simple fact
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations these
things can just destroy your business
you didn't get into business because you
wish to worry about hr everybody thinks
about hr and they think about toby from
the office because that's kind of what
hr is but if you don't get it taken care
of it can really come back and just bite
you directly on the surface hr manager
salaries they're not cheap they're an
average of 70 000 bucks a year bambi is
spelled b-a-m-b-e-e it was created
specifically for small business you can
get a dedicated hr manager craft hr
policy maintain your compliance all for
just 99 bucks a month with bambi you can
change hr from your biggest liability to
your biggest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone email or
real-time chat from onboarding
determinations that customize your
policies to fit your business and help
you manage your employees day-to-day all
for just 99 bucks a month they're
month-to-month no hidden fees you can
cancel any time you didn't start your
business because you wanted to spend
time on hr compliance let bambi help get
your free hr audits today go to
bambi.com shapiro right now to schedule
your free hr audit that is bambi.com
shapiro again
b-a-m-b-e-e dot com slash apparel go
check them out right now bambi.com
shapiro we know that the narratives that
are formed in the lead-up to criminal
cases obviously have an impact on both
juries and how prosecutions conduct
their case and we saw this in the
derrick chauvin trial where without any
evidence whatsoever that case was made
the face the bleeding edge of racism in
the united states there was no evidence
that children was racist it was not even
alleged in the courtroom the media
instead decided it was a referendum on
all cops and referendum on racism in the
united states with written house they
did the same thing they said this is a
referendum somehow on racism
okay now they're having a tough time
with this one because rittenhouse number
one is not a white supremacist and
number two the people he shot were all
white
all three had criminal records one of
them was a child child molester
so
this was not the the best case to pick
if you're a member of the media and you
wish to talk about the evils of domestic
terror white supremacists running around
but the goal you have to remember when
this happened with written house was to
posit that there was a great conflict in
the nation between the morally just blm
rioters and trump supporters who were
evil that was the conflict they were
trying to create this case didn't fit
inside that conflict at all the conflict
itself was stupid it didn't make any
sense but the media had a narrative and
whatever the narrative had to be they
were going to cram this into it well
this is where you would expect the
system of justice to actually do its job
and stand aside they didn't the system
of justice decided
that that it was necessary to bring a
criminal case against kyle rittenhouse
because of the public pressure and at
the time again i was willing to withhold
judgment until i saw all the evidence
now he's seen all the evidence let me
just tell you this prosecutor ought to
be disbarred there is no way this case
should have been brought it's insane
that this case was brought based on the
evidence so kyle written house yesterday
takes the stand now as a lawyer i got to
tell you first year criminal law they
tell you if you got a client do not let
your client take the stand because
especially uh like unless the evidence
really runs against you and you feel
that it is definitely necessary that you
need your clients to take the stand you
don't put your client on the stand
because you just don't know what's gonna
happen courtrooms are unpredictable
juries are unpredictable you don't know
how they're going to react to particular
testimony okay but ridden house decided
to take the stand
and again that that's kind of an
incredible thing you got to remember
it's an incredible thing because the
prosecutor had completely failed to make
his case in the days leading up to this
i mean i did a lot on the podcast monday
about this in the days leading up to
yesterday
written houses prosecutors did a
horrible job they were calling witness
after witness
the prosecution and those witnesses were
quickly turning into defense witnesses
gage gross clothes or whatever the guy's
name is he he was the guy who was shot
in the arm by written house
he was asked by the prosecutor if he was
if he was if he had dropped his gun or
or what was going on and instead he was
like oh yeah yeah i was putting my gun
at him i mean he literally just made the
defense case for the defense it was
incredible
and that sort of testimony was very
common the prosecutor would call a
witness the witness would testify to
written house's innocence and then the
prosecutor would kind of throw up his
hands
so finally written house takes the stand
yesterday
and it didn't go great for the
prosecution
okay so let's begin with clip 29 okay so
the prosecutor asks him about one of the
people that he shot guy named huber
okay and and this is the guy who if you
recall the footage
just to go through the timeline here
written house was running away from a
fire there was a big fire and
rittenhouse was running away from the
fire and a and a man confronted him and
started yelling at him apparently he had
confronted him earlier in the night
this would be joseph rosenbaum and
started chasing him
ridden house ran away even though i did
a gun right he'd been there to kill him
shot him there he wasn't he ran away
rosenbaum chased him down
and ridden house turned around rosenbaum
grabbed for his gun and written house
shot him
ridden house then stood there
as a reporter came over reporter from
the daily caller came over and and tried
to provide medical aid to rosenberg who
was bleeding out and a crowd started
together and written house didn't feel
safe he started trying to run toward the
cops
as he was running toward the cops he was
pursued by a bunch of antifa thugs
one of those antifa thugs was hoover who
jumped on him with a skateboard and
started trying to clock him in the head
with the skateboard
okay because he was now prone he'd
fallen down and tripped and fallen
and rittenhouse shot
huber and then
gage gross croots decided that he was
going to get in on the action and he ran
over with his pistol
pointed at written house and written how
shot him in the arm
okay that is the timeline here
so actually let's start with uh with
clip two so rittenhouse
it was asked by the prosecutor why he
was running and he says because there
was a fire
you decided you needed to run because of
the fire on the duramax yes why what was
so urgent
it was a fire
there's fires all over the place so
i was getting to the fire to put it out
we'll get back to that in a second
okay so
great job here great job
um good job prosecutor why were you
running to a fire well there are fires
everywhere why why are you running that
fire
uh excuse me
i have a question is that also how you
like
well if a firefighter gets a phone call
and he says go to a fire
would you say to him there are many
other fires in the city sir why aren't
you going to those as well like that
what are you even talking about
what are you talking about
okay
then the prosecutor asks you know why
did you shoot this anthony huber
character this 26 year old who is
swinging a skateboard at him
and um
rittenhouse gives the obvious answer
because he was trying to hit me in the
head with his skateboard which could
kill me
and when you
shoot him
he's got his skateboard in his hand
yes
you didn't see
any gun in his hand correct
you didn't see a knife no you didn't see
a bat no you didn't see a club no all
he's got is the skateboard right that
he's hit me in the head with twice yes
okay
and he's hitting me in the head with
twice
okay as it turns out under american law
i don't have to wait for you to hit me
in the head with a skateboard the third
time
once you've hit me in the head with the
skateboard the first time i can by the
way if you come at me with a skateboard
and you swing back and you're about to
hit me in the head i can shoot you
before you hit me
self-defense is still a part of american
law and by the way all
western common law and by the way all
non-western law
okay like i'm unaware of any state
anywhere where self-defense is not a
thing where if somebody swings a
skateboard at your head you're supposed
to just stand there and take it
okay and then the prosecutor suggests
the written house is just out to shoot
people
and ridden how's like uh i didn't want
to shoot people i mean you can see in
the tape that he's holding back from
shooting people
you just assumed
that he was going to use it
that he was going to try and take it
from you first of all and then you
assumed he was going to try and use it
on you
if i would have let mr roosevelt get my
gun he would have killed me
but you had already pointed your gun at
him yes because he was chasing me did
you want him to think that you were
going to shoot him no i never wanted to
shoot mr rosenbaum
why'd you point it at him if you didn't
have any intention of shooting
he was chasing me i was alone he
threatened to kill me
earlier in that night
i didn't want to have to shoot him
okay i love how the prosecutor suggests
that if you point a gun in the vicinity
of a person who is chasing you with
violent intent to threaten to kill you
that this me and then you don't shoot
this means you meant to shoot
okay and then written house is asked
about the the third character who
attacked him gage gross crudes
and um and he says to him you know you
had a rifle he had a pistol so what made
you think you had to shoot him i don't
understand does this prosecutor not
understand how guns operate
like what what
this is not a video game
a pistol can kill you just as easily as
a rifle can particularly when you're
about eight feet apart as they are in
the video
they are on top of one another
this is not kyle rittenhouse out at
sniper distance engaged gross crews
walking around the perimeter carrying a
pistol
this is gage grosskroot pulling a gun
out raising it up about 10 feet away
from kyle rittenhouse who's prone on his
back here's the prosecutor this
prosecutor's a mockery he's just a
mockery
he's got a pistol not aimed at you
you've got an ar-15 aimed at him why is
he more of a threat to you
than you are to him
because he wasn't he was moving at me
with a gun in his hand
this is right after you've killed
anthony huber correct yes right after
you fired two shots at almost
point-blank range at the man running
towards the camera right now and missing
him correct yes
and you're telling us
gage grosskroyd's is the real threat at
this moment
yes
i mean yeah
have you seen the video like i don't
know how
ass backwards you have to be not to be
able to to watch that video and come
away with the idea that great gage gross
which is not a lethal threat
if a man a pro if you fall on the on
your back you're running away from
people you fall on your back you got
your rifle here somebody approaches you
with his pistol he's withdrawing it
to shoot you
and the prosecutor is like why would you
feel like you were in dire threat you
mean he wasn't coming to give you like a
christmas present he wasn't coming over
they'd give you a nice troll how do you
know maybe he was gonna drop the pistol
and come over there and give you a bear
hug
maybe he's gonna give you a foot massage
like what in the world what in the
actual so written houses asked why were
you trying to get to the cops after the
first shooting why are you trying to get
to the cops and he says because i was
defending myself like what do you not
understand about the english language
sir
people were saying cranium him and get
him
kill him
people were screaming and i just was
trying to get to the police running down
sheridan road and you say i'm trying to
get to the police why were you trying to
get to the police so i didn't do
anything wrong i defended myself
okay so this testimony goes very very
poorly for the prosecution like super
poorly for the prosecution but the left
has to have its narrative because
remember they've doubled down on the
notion that written house is white
supremacist murderer who went out that
night to shoot people the evidence is
precisely the opposite it does not
matter they have to have their victim
they have to have their their blood here
and written house has to go down so they
need something to hang their hat on and
what they decide to hang their hat on is
the fact that written house cried
yesterday at the trial
that is what they've hung their hat on
okay so
yesterday rittenhouse is is getting beat
up by the prosecutor he's being asked
over and over about shooting people he's
18 years old so he's a young man now the
reason i use the term young man here is
because i want to be consistent right
michael brown was also a young man when
he attacked a police officer and when he
was shot for his trouble
okay so when you're 17 years old 18
years old i'm i'm hesitant in a criminal
justice context to use different
terminology for different people based
on based on the age right if you're 17
18 years old you are now a young man so
so
written house in this in if you were if
you were a kid then
not only should he not have been out on
the street there had been no excuse for
him to be out on the street if he's 14
years old 13 years old but he's 17 years
old he's out there he's a young man okay
so
that does not mean that it's not rather
an emotional thing when you're on trial
for your life for having shot three
career criminals essentially
okay so so written house is being beat
up by the prosecutor and he starts
crying
and it was
pretty intense testimony right he
essentially has a panic attack
that's basically what happens on the
stand
and frankly i can't really blame him
i mean if you were called to testify for
your life in a trial that was so
ridiculous on its face
and
and you knew that you'd had to shoot
three people
you hadn't wanted to shoot going out
there you brought the gun to defend
yourself and you had to defend yourself
that's not an easy thing and now you're
on trial for your life with a prosecutor
who's attacking you for shooting people
attempting to hit you in the head with a
skateboard and approaching you to grab
your gun and alternatively trying to
point a pistol at you
you might have a panic attack on the
stand too and that's essentially what
happened with with written house
yesterday here's what that sounded like
once i take that step back i look over
my shoulder and
mr rosenbaum
mr rosenbaum was now running
from
my right side
and
i was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and there were
people right there
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so
the media's response to this in large
part is he's lying this shows he's a
fake there are people who are tweeting
out photos of him next to of course
brett kavanaugh because
all white people who cry are apparently
the same and not only that also brett
kavanaugh we know was lying because he
got upset too it turns out that when
you're up when you are accused of a
thing you did not do you tend to get
upset but apparently according to the
media
your your tears are some sign of guilt
so you have for example
lebron james who tweeted out
lebron is just i'm sorry lebron is just
kind of a garbage human i mean he's just
a bad person he's just a bad person
a person who spends all day whining
about how america is deeply racist while
he becomes one of the wealthiest people
in the country
who bullies people into saying nothing
about chinese human rights violations
but he has time to suggest that kyle
rittenhouse is um
is lying and this is all false here's
what lebron james tweeted quote what
tiers five question marks
i didn't see one
man knock it off that boy ate some lemon
heads before walking into court
and then three emojis of laughing crying
yeah i mean
coming from a guy who uh who acts like a
soccer player on the court frequently
i i will not take acting lessons from
lebron james
and uh and i've noticed that um
[Music]
again lebron lebron has a lot to say
when it comes to defending the chinese
government and
pretty much nothing to say when it comes
to the question of due process for
people he doesn't particularly like
what what a god send lebron james's
he has every right to speak his mind and
frankly i'm glad he does because he
demonstrates what kind of person he is
pretty much every time he goes on
twitter
you'll recall this is not the last time
it's not the first time lebron james has
had to to do this
you remember that that just back in
april he had to delete a tweet about a
police shooting of makia bryant in
columbus ohio right you'll remember that
makia bryant was a 16 year old black
girl who was attacking another black
girl with a knife and a cop drove up and
had to shoot her
and lebron james tweeted out
in giant letters you're next all caps
your next hashtag accountability and an
hourglass emoji
and then added i'm so damn tired of
seeing black people killed by police i
took the tweet down because it's being
used to create more hate it's about the
entire system they always use our words
to create more racism i'm so desperate
for more accountability
yeah sure lebron what a delight he is we
need more we we need more of lebron's
insightful political commentary to make
the world a better place really
in space jam 3 i look forward to him
maligning an innocent person i mean
milan's an innocent cop for saving a
black person and now he's maligning kyle
rittenhouse is a guy who eats lemonheads
before going into court while he's on
trial for his life
space jam 3 should just be about in an
innocent person being victimized and
lebron james standing on them and
spitting
th that's what space jam 3 should be
about what what a genius he is
meanwhile miriam webster got into the
act
you want your local dictionary to get
into the act on these things it's very
very important so merriam-webster
tweeted out
the term crocodile tears a superficial
display of anguish comes from a medieval
belief that crocodiles shed tears of
sadness when killing their prey
they tweeted that out in the middle of
the trial
because merriam-webster is now run their
twitter account at least is run by
wokesters so people who literally are
defining the words you use in english
are
sounding off this way in the middle of a
trial
hakeem jeffries
a progressive congressman from new york
he gets in on the act he tweets out lock
up kyle rittenhouse and throw away the
key
based on what exactly based on what
anna navarro
you're a supposed in-house republican in
places like cnn in the view
she tweets out kyle rittenhouse shot and
killed anthony hubert 26 and joseph
rosenbaum 36 and injured gage gross
groots now 27. think about how much
their loved ones have cried real anguish
and grief not crocodile tears
hey by the way um you can see in this
picture the actual tears are on his face
so uh when so lebron is not only stupid
he's blind apparently but uh anna
navarro here saying that um you have to
think about the families of joseph
rosenbaum who was a child molester a
serial child molester and gauge gross
groups was attacking a 17 year old who's
prone on the ground with a pistol and
anthony huber
who had a criminal record and was
swinging a swinging a skateboard at this
guy's head think about how much their
loved ones have cried real anguishing if
not crocodile tears see he cried that
was a big problem as he cried benjamin
dixon another blue check on twitter
tweeted out similarly proud boys is
trending not looking so proud now are
you boy
the language here is really quite a
delight quite a delight ryan grimm from
the intercept joins he says what people
could do with anger about the written
house trial is to advocate for a law
that says that if you bring a weapon to
a public place where you know violence
is basically guaranteed you lose any
self-defense grounds
uh that makes
that makes a lot of sense so basically
if you bring a weapon to defend yourself
to any unsafe area in the united states
and someone attacks you you can now be
murdered at whim
great job everyone that makes perfect
sense great job everyone
okay so you can see
with this sort of climate
that's the reason the prosecutor brought
this thing
this thing because there's no other
reason for him to have brought this case
he's got nothing he's got less than
nothing he made himself look like a fool
this trial is a joke it's been a joke
beginning to i kept waiting honest to
god i kept waiting for them to bring
forth the piece of evidence that we
hadn't seen already and then every
additional piece of evidence was worse
for the prosecution
as somebody who generally wants to
uphold institutional trust
as somebody who believes the criminal
justice system
is imperfect but generally does a decent
job it is hard to watch trials like this
and believe that sort of thing
i'm gonna chalk this one up to a bad
apple in the prosecutor but it seems
more and more often that criminal
justice trials are now being brought
simply because of public pressure
brought by the media the media can whip
up an outrage and then you just use the
prosecutor as the as the head of the mob
in order to go after somebody it's
really disgusting
really by the way the judge agrees we'll
get to that in just one second first i'm
thrilled to introduce an incredible app
that everyone who buys gas right now
needs to know about get upside my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download the free get upside app
in the app store or google play right
now use promo code shapiro get a bonus
25 cents per gallon on your first fill
up that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price at the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free use promo code shapiro
to get up to 50 cents per gallon cash
back on your first tank some people who
drive a lot are making as much as two to
three hundred bucks a month in cash back
there is no catch the cash back gets
added directly to your account
you can cash out any time to your bank
account paypal or an egift card for
amazon and other brands just download
the free get upside app use promo code
shapiro to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your very first tank of gas
that's promo code shapiro you may have
noticed that the gas prices are
completely out of control thanks to joe
biden's inflationary spiral well that
would be a great time to save on gas go
to the get upside app right now download
it use promo code trapezoid up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank and 25 cents for every gallon of
gas after that go check them out right
now okay so
this thing went super poorly for the
prosecutor not just according to people
who are sort of watching the trial but
according to the judge so the prosecutor
i don't know
how disbarmand is not considered here
seriously the prosecutor
twice
essentially got called on the carpet by
the judge
who was very very pissed off and for
good reason
okay and the reason that the judge was
pissed off is in the first incident in
the first instance
the lawyer attempted to make the
argument during cross-examination
about
why he'd remain silent after his arrest
so when he was arrested he didn't talk
to the police
now it is a well-established rule i mean
literally going back centuries that
silence is not an admission of guilt
okay this goes all the way back to like
the thomas more trial
the the belief that if you are silent on
a particular topic this means that you
are guilty
as well as the notion that if you take
the fifth amendment that this is an
implication of guilt in a courtroom
you're not allowed to even bring that up
if you're a lawyer in a courtroom
you're not allowed to
okay that's like black letter again
first year law
and the judge just reams the prosecutor
for attempting to do that i mean the
prosecutor did that he's like why did
you're really attempting to make the
argument that kyle written house not
talking to the cops means that he's
guilty
they get by the way
again quick lawyer rule guys hey if you
are ever arrested for a crime call your
lawyer and say nothing to the cops if
you're ever arrested for a crime call
your lawyer say nothing to the cops
again first year basic law
and it doesn't mean you're guilty it
means that you need to talk to your
lawyer because the police are there to
do their job and that job might involve
asking questions that implicate you in
crimes you didn't commit for example so
you always want to work with your lawyer
okay but
one thing that's not allowed to happen
is in the courtroom the opposing lawyer
isn't allowed to say because you didn't
talk to the cops this means you're
guilty
that that gets rid of the purpose of the
fifth amendment in the first place
here is uh here's the prosecutor just
getting ringed by the judge for this one
you are already you were i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that i said i
had heard nothing in this trial to
change any of my rulings so why
testimony pardon me that was before that
get brazen with me you're an experienced
trial attorney and you're telling me
that when the judge says i'm excluding
this you just to take it upon yourself
to put it in because you think that
you've found a way around it come on
okay and then the judge says i don't
believe that you're acting in good faith
okay the second thing he's commenting on
there is that there was a piece of
evidence that was ruled out pre-trial
okay that piece of evidence has nothing
to do with the case it comes from like a
month after hal rittenhouse got out on
bail she's talking about months after
the initial incident and he was
photographed in a bar with members of
the proud boys wearing a shirt that said
free as f
okay that is not relevant to his state
of mind on the day that he shot people
that is not relevant okay that was
declared out of evidence by the judge
because when it comes to criminal trials
you have to weigh prejudicial
evidence against the probative value of
the evidence what that means is that for
example in a criminal trial you're
generally not allowed to bring up the
criminal history of the person who is on
trial because that does not go into the
calculation as to whether the person
committed this particular crime so if
something happens three months after an
incident in which you're wearing a shirt
that's offensive and stupid does that
have anything to do with whether you
committed the particular crime that is
in question three months earlier
the answer of course is no it does not
and the judge had already ruled that out
he'd already said i'm ruling that out if
you want to like approach me later and
ask about it you can but
it's out for now right i'll leave the
door open to myself but not to you this
prosecutor just started bringing up the
evidence that had already essentially
been ruled out in the first place and
the judge is like you can't do that i
know what you're doing here
i mean that this prompted by the way the
defense to ask for a mistrial without
the ability of refiling
a mistrial of prejudice saying just end
the case right now
by the way like i wouldn't be surprised
if this trial never goes to the jury
that's that's how that's how bad this is
he says the judge just went after him
and then according to the associated
press
the defense asked for a mistrial over
what appeared to be an out-of-bounds
question asked of written house by the
chief prosecutor the judge should not
immediately rule on the request the
judge did say that the kind of activity
that the prosecutor engaged in here
essentially
was um
was
bordering on
mistrial it was certainly grounds for an
appeal if rittenhouse were to be
convicted
it was it was so
it's so weak how weak was was the
prosecution's case i mean this one sums
it up how weak was the prosecution case
the prosecutor tried to link kyle
rittenhouse
and his self-defense claim
with playing call of duty i kid you not
this is a thing that happened in real
life in a courtroom
did this get does this lawyer get his
degree from a cracker jack box
like did he just mail in a bunch of box
stops and they sent him a lawyer's
degree
honest to god i want to know where he
went to law school because he apparently
went to law school at like the fisher
price school of law or something
here we go
isn't it true when you would hang out at
with dominic black you'd play call of
duty and other first-person shooter
video games
sometimes and those are games in which
you use weapons like ar-15s to pretty
much shoot anybody who comes at you
correct
it's a video game where two players are
playing together
i don't really understand the meaning of
your question to be honest isn't one of
the things people do in these video
games try and kill everyone else with
your guns
yeah the video game it's just a video
game it's not real life
so i i love that kyle written now has to
explain to him that video games are not
real life
well done here sir well done and
michigan university the university of
michigan law school should be
extraordinarily proud
by the way
binger ran as a democratic candidate for
the position of district attorney in
racine county and was appointed kenosha
county d.a about 18 months ago just
really well done here so the media are
now reacting to this with their usual
aplomb they're attacking the judge
and they're saying that's the big
problem here the judge is now going to
come under fire we'll get to that in
just one moment first let's talk about
refining your home so as you've been
seeing the the fed is now talking about
tapering that means mortgage rates at
some point in the near future are
probably going to start going up you
would imagine because of the
inflationary spiral the biden has sent
us into if you're looking at refining
your mortgage you really should get in
under the water and go do it right now
it's a strategic approach that makes
sense for a lot of folks since rates
remain at near all-time lows making it a
great time to call american financing
learn about custom loan options that can
save you up to a thousand bucks a month
that's right every month because they do
more than just lower your rate they look
at your entire financial picture finding
every way to help you save no pressure
no obligation no upfront or hidden fees
so why not learn more i'll give you a
free mortgage review you might skip two
payments if you choose to move forward
pre-qualify for free by calling
866-721-3300
3300 or visit americanfinancing.net and
mls182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org again go check them
out
americanfinancing.net or prequalify for
a mortgage review for free by calling
thirty three hundred that's eight six
six seven two one thirty three hundred
all right we'll get to more on written
house and and bite inflation in just one
second first when it comes to joe
biden's vaccine mandate daily wire is
not backing down so as you know
with your help and your support we filed
a lawsuit against this tyrannical
unconstitutional mandate a week ago
today the fifth circuit court of appeals
has already issued a temporary stay over
the weekend preventing biden's mandate
from going into effect they cited quote
grave statutory and constitutional
issues that's just the first step
it will be appealed to the supreme court
we are fighting it in the sixth circuit
okay it is likely to end up at the
supreme court and we are i'm sure going
to be one of the companies fighting it
one of the rare companies that's
fighting it the fact is that we are not
just fighting for our own employees we
want this thing struck down for everyone
right we are fighting not just for the
medical freedom of americans who are
facing termination we're fighting for
basic american freedom from
authoritarian overreach by the
administrative state you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so when the media aren't attacking kyle
rittenhouse for the great sin of crying
on the stand you know while he's on
trial for murder
in a clear self-defense case they're
very upset about that and steven crowder
i thought made an excellent point about
this the same people who will tell you
that it should be verboten in american
life to call people by their biological
pronouns because it might hurt their
feelings are the exact same people who
are laughing at kyle rittenhouse for
crying on the stand in a murder trial
where he's being wrongly accused of
murder
yeah these people are
not not not great people not not great
bob okay so the media have now taken a
new attack the new attack is uh that the
judge is real bad that's that's the new
tag the judge is a meanie bad meanie
who's bad according to the new york
times the judge was clashed with
prosecutors has been in this business
for 50 years that's according to the new
york times they have a long piece about
this bruce schrader the longest serving
circuit judge in wisconsin
is presiding over the homicide trial of
kyle rittenhouse at times during written
house's testimony on wednesday he took a
strict line with prosecutors clashing
with them over a reference to written
house's silence in the months before the
trial and an attempt to introduce
testimony on a previous incident the
judge had ruled inadmissible judge
schroeder 75 who has said he believes he
has seen more homicide trials than any
other judge in the state graduated from
marquette law school in 1970 worked as a
prosecutor and began serving as a
circuit judge in 1983.
his longevity is the subject of frequent
conversation in the courtroom in kenosha
legal senator his circles judge
schroeder has a reputation for
strictness in sentencing he's known for
delivering lectures to prospective
jurors about their civic duty which in
this trial he likened to serving as an
american soldier in vietnam he
frequently complains about media bias
and the impact news coverage can have on
prospective jurors edge as judge
schrader quizzed prospective jurors he
said he has read news articles on the
written house case has asked himself
whether he was in the same courtroom
that was described in the articles he
has also acknowledged that some of the
topics raised in pre-trial hearings are
new to him until this case judge
schrader said in a hearing he'd never
heard of the proud boys
the first time i saw it or a version of
it was chef boyardee on a can of
spaghetti because the okay hand signal
is what he's talking about
in one of the judge's highest profile
cases the 2008 murder trial of mark
jensen who's accused of poisoning his
wife with anti-freeze and smothering her
a conviction was overturned when
appellate courts and the state supreme
court ruled that schroeder had
improperly allowed evidence in the trial
the judge allowed the prosecution to
present a letter that julie jensen had
written and given to a neighbor as well
as a voicemail message she left for a
police officer suggesting if anything
happened her her husband would be
responsible so another k in other words
the only case that they can find on this
judge that was overturned is because he
was too favorable to the prosecution
but apparently this means he's very bad
the judge is very so the new york times
is going after the judge you've got the
washington post
saying as kyle rittenhouse trial near's
end judge's decisions from the bench
come under scrutiny
regardless of how he is viewed judge
bruce schrader is indisputably a man
with fixed rules for how trials in his
kenosha county courtroom will be run
some are basic some unorthodox all
reflect the experience of a jurist who
believes trials can be too easily
manipulated particularly by the
prosecution
for a jury trial if you get him you're
happy as a defense attorney said michael
ciccini a criminal defense lawyer in
kenosha wisconsin
he's appeared before schrader numerous
times including earlier this year in
that case he won an acquittal for his
client who's charged with battery
schrader's reputation has summoned
kenosha worried the 75-year-old judge is
running the trial of kyle rittenhouse
the defense has already logged some wins
in schroeder's courtroom
gage grosskroot's the man who survived
written house's gunfire took the witness
stand for the prosecution but
acknowledged he was pointing his gun at
rittenhouse when the teenager fired at
him then as the prosecution rested its
case schroeder dismissed a charge for
his alleged failure to comply with
curfew the judge said he agreed with
defense attorneys the prosecution had
not entered sufficient evidence to prove
a curfew was even in effect and then he
got sharp with the prosecutor
it seems like he's aiming to let this
man out of his courtroom scot-free we're
not gonna let that happen said justin
blake whose nephew jacob blake was shot
by the police last year triggering
knights of unrest by the way if he's
friendly to the defense i'm finding it
kind of hysterical that the same people
who are all in on defending career
criminals
are like yeah but we can't have a judge
who's pro who's pro defense
that would be scary so in other words
exactly the kind of judge you would be
looking for if jacob blake was on trial
and you're an ally of jacob blake you
don't want for written house
i've noticed a slight difference in how
you're treating
prospective criminal cases i've i've
just noticed i've just noticed so
basically he's too liberal
he's too liberal is the rap against him
so now that's bad according to the
washington post
he's too liberal with defendants
i'm again getting the impression
that
the media are mostly
uh are mostly interested
in a verdict that they like
according to the washington post while
generally respected schroeder is not
universally loved and has been accused
of overstepping his authority he once
ordered a woman convicting of
shoplifting to inform an employee of any
retail store she entered she was under
supervision for her theft
in another case from the 1980s schrader
ordered a babysitter accused of
molesting a child to submit to an aids
chest
aids test he began requiring sex workers
who appeared before him to do the same
there's no statutory authority for him
to do that
but he's been on the cutting edge of a
lot of cases well what a terrible man
what a terrible horrible man
clearly he will be to blame if the
prosecutor brought a crappy case and the
media went completely over its skis in
order to push a false narrative about
what was happening in kenosha and used
kyle rittenhouse as their case in point
to prove american white supremacy
for a white guy who shot a bunch of
other white guys
really
genius genius stuff
and faith in institutions has been
shaken here and it should be shaken
and and i would recommend that uh
everybody take the same
attitude when it comes to these criminal
trials as uh as we should all be taking
i think which is wait to see how the
evidence shakes out before you
immediately assume the institutions are
doing their job because of late they
have not been okay meanwhile
inflation hit a 30-year high according
to reports yesterday by the way it just
missed like if it had been slightly
higher it would have been maybe a
50-year high like since the late 1970s
according to the wall street journal u.s
inflation hit a three-decade high in
october delivering widespread sizable
price increases to households for
everything from groceries to cars due to
persistent supply shortages and strong
consumer demand the labor department
said the consumer price index which
measures what consumers pay for goods
and services increased in october by 6.2
percent from a year ago that was the
fastest 12-month pace since 1990 again
just missed since like 1978
and the fifth straight month of
inflation above five percent the core
price index climbed 4.6 in october from
a year earlier
on a monthly basis the consumer price
index increased a seasonally adjusted
0.9 percent in october from the prior
month that is a sharp acceleration from
0.4 in september and the same as june's
0.9
remember the bite administration was
suggesting 2 inflation across the year
we are now talking about 6 percent
inflation across the year well over 6
annualized inflation
that is scary as all hell for many
people who are attempting to just live
in the country and by the way
inflation has completely wiped out all
wage gains wage gains in the united
states no longer exist because inflation
is just too high all of the wage gains
have now been taken away according to
cnbc
the labor department reported on friday
the average hourly earnings increased
0.4 in october but
top line inflation was 0.9 percent which
means you might have been earning more
but you were spending way more than you
were earning
real hour real average hourly earnings
when accounting for inflation actually
decreased 0.5 percent for the month so
when joe biden brags about how wages are
rising understand that in real terms
they are falling
wages have swelled since the beginning
of the year average hourly earnings are
up 4.9 year-over-year in october but
compared with inflation which is what
you actually care about real hourly
wages have declined more than 1.2
percent during the same time frame
according to the labor department
so you're like oh look a five percent
raise oh wait all of the products are
six percent more expensive
[Music]
sad music from the prices right there
okay even uh cnn is slamming joe biden
for this inflationary spiral and
remember when they say transitory they
said transitory um it's not transitory
it has not been
transitory uh once once it's there
it's there here is uh
here's cnn's anna cabrera slamming biden
for his inflationary policy
if you feel like your dollar is being
stretched then you are not alone and the
latest inflation data just today
is sobering proof consumer prices are
surging more than they have in 30 years
and to make matters worse there's no
sign it'll get better anytime soon we
knew that this inflation report would be
brutal but this was much worse than
expected new vehicle prices were up by
nearly 10 year-over-year that is the
biggest increase that we've seen since
1975 it is never a good sign when you're
making inflation comparisons with the
1970s
okay meanwhile politico is reporting
surging gas and grocery prices are
constant reminders of inflation but
another creeping trend spells more
trouble for people's wallets and
democratics and democrats political fate
rising rent housing costs just posted
one of their largest monthly gains in
decades many economists expect them to
loom large in inflation figures over the
next year heading into the 2022 midterm
elections it's not just economists the
federal reserve bank of new york said in
research released monday that americans
on average expect rents to rise 10
over the next year the highest reading
in the history of the survey
robert dietz the chief economist at the
national association of homebuilders
says quote we could face an economy a
year from now where some of the supply
chain disruptions are going to ease and
price growth will ease but housing is
likely to be the one
where we are going to continue to see
cost growth and that will have an impact
on households
63 percent of americans in a recent poll
say that they are very concerned about
the rising cost of food and consumer
goods in a poll of more than 10 000
adults conducted by pew
that's a one reason why joe biden's
failed policies are having a real impact
on his approval ratings he's down in the
high 30s low 40s
even joe biden seems stunned by what joe
biden has unleashed so joe biden did a
presser yesterday in which he was
stunned to learn that he's presidents of
the united states and things are bad
we got higher demand for goods at the
same time we're facing disruptions in
the supplies to make those goods
there's a res this is a recipe for
delays and for higher prices and people
are feeling it
they're feeling it do everything keep
paying this much for a guy a gallon of
gas
in some parts of california they're
paying 4.50 cents a gallon
that's why it's so important we do
everything on our power to stabilize the
supply chain
okay so i i love that did you ever think
you'd be paying this much
uh
well no but that's your fault
i'm pretty sure it was it was you i mean
aren't you the president and right now i
love this he's out there in baltimore
that's where he is touting the
infrastructure plan
which just tossed 1.2 trillion dollars
more into the spending hopper so
inflation is spiraling out of control
he just tossed over a trillion dollars
in new spending
out there with the help of some idiot
republicans and many many idiot
democrats
and he is that's what he's touting in
the middle of an inflationary spiral
and he continues along these lines
admitting that everything costs more
man
he's just making campaign ads for
republicans now
today's economic report showing
unemployment continued to fall
but consumer prices remain too high
tell us
american people in the midst of this
economic crisis the recovery is showing
strong results but not to them they're
still looking out there everything from
a gallon of gas to loaf of bread costs
more and it's worrisome even though
wages are going up
[Applause]
so this uh senile old man is going to
jabber at you about how he will save
everything by spending more money he's
touting the bipartisan infrastructure
plan and for some odd reason he started
jabbering about how people get their
internet from mcdonald's now i don't
know if this is a major thing i will
admit
it has been a rare circumstance where
i've been in the car and i haven't had
internet and i have to pull over
someplace and try and
leach onto somebody else's wi-fi but i'm
just wondering it's like a major thing
that lots of people do really and also
why would that justify 1.2 trillion
dollars in spending in the middle of an
inflationary spiral here's joe biden
being incoherent as per his usual
arrangement with with the with reality
and words
those of you have kids in school when
we've been going this hybrid thing some
in class some out of class
how many times if you haven't if you
don't live in an area where you have
high speed internet you can afford
how many times you've driven your kids
to the parking lot of mcdonald's and sat
there
going off the mcdonald's internet so you
could hear no i'm not joking
think of this united states america for
god's sake
uh
hard hurting those huh
sort of hybrid and you're having
mcdonald's and like their hashbrowns but
their their fish sandwich is kind of
soggy and they're high in the kids
around you need to hear you need to hear
you're seeing your kid's zoom class at
mcdonald's in the parking lots
and by the way
he's not done yet and he says he wants
much much more spending that's the
solution more spending magical green
jobs at 45 dollars an hour
yes yes inflate the labor in
artificially inflate the price of labor
that will have no impact on the costs
that are passed down to consumers
thereby driving up inflation even more
yes if you if you helicopter cash to
people that will definitely help with
the inflationary spiral we're in
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
create good paying union jobs union
not a good job not 12 an hour not 15 an
hour 45 bucks an hour i'm up with good
benefits so you can raise the family on
and build the middle class out
and jobs it cannot be outsourced you
can't outsource these jobs
um
okay so my favorite thing about joe
biden is is the statement he put out
yesterday on this so you put it down
here's the statement you put out
yesterday on inflation you ready today
we received two pieces of economic news
which underscored that our recovery is
continuing to progress but that we also
have more work to do before our economy
is back to normal back to normal first
unemployment we learned that we have had
six consecutive weeks of decline in new
unemployment claims by the way that
dates back to wait for it wait for it
the end of unemployment benefits
democrats wanted to extend the rest of
the year then he says on inflation
today's report shows an increase over
last month inflation hurts americans
pocketbooks and reversing this trend is
a top priority for me so what is he
going to do
he says that he's directed the national
economic council to pursue means to
reduce costs he's asked the ftc to
strike back at market manipulation or
price gouging yes price and wage
controls that's what we've been missing
since the 70s we need those back price
and wage controls that'll definitely
help things
also his infrastructure bill is going to
help things by spending lots of money
following fewer goods and also we need
bill back better isn't it incredible how
all the circumstances point to him doing
to all the things he already wanted to
do isn't that amazing he had a plan and
then circumstances changed
and then the solution is still his plan
isn't that incredible he wanted to push
trillions of dollars in new spending and
then it turns out that we're an
inflationary spiral but magically the
way that we get out of the inflationary
spiral is with trillions of dollars in
new spending
incredible
now ceos of major american companies are
starting to freak out we've looked at
the stock market yesterday which
declined even well the treasury yields
started to go up meaning that fewer
people were invested the price of the
bonds was going down and so is the price
people are like pulling their money out
they're starting to freak out
according to politico spiking inflation
underscored by two government reports
this week showing the biggest price
surges in decades presents a powerful
threat to the economy as it struggles to
shake off the pandemic executives say
the ceo of one of the us's largest
companies who spoke on condition of
anonymity out of concern for over
angering the administration because
that's what we do in this country now
our capitalist overlords are in complete
cahoots with the democratic party so
often these days
you've got corporate overlords listen i
love laissez faire let me explain i i'm
more free market than nearly anyone in
american public life and there's
something deeply wrong with free markets
when the heads of major corporations
have to be afraid of mentioning that
inflationary policies are bad for fear
of pissing off the president who might
then sick the government on them he says
i don't think the administration is on
top of it at all how many people inside
this white house really know what
inflation is or how it impacts
businesses it's not really their fault
it's been so long since we had it
many executives are flying blind growing
increasingly worried that washington
politics in which democrats want to
spend hundreds of billions more on joe
biden's agenda and fed church rome
powell wants to avoid denting the labor
market while biden weighs nominating him
for a second term we'll block any real
steps to address inflation before it
gets worse
the executives would like to see less
eye-popping spending proposals stronger
moves to boost supply chains more
pressure on powell to speed up his
efforts to choke off rising prices
but they're all doing it with limited
real-world experience so ceos are going
uh you guys don't know what the hell
you're doing but we're afraid to say
that directly to you because if we do
we're afraid you're going to punish us
publicly because you guys are so
anti-business
now if you want to take a what should be
the greatest gangbusters economy in
human history and spiral it into
recession this is a great way to do it
meanwhile i got janet yellen
who is
as bright as a bag of bricks
explaining that inflation is no longer
something that americans should really
worry about it's not that big a deal
in the 1970s we saw supply shocks
turn
themselves into
endemic inflation we're not seeing that
now i don't believe we will
but if that were the case the federal
reserve would have a role to play to
keep it under control that happened in
the 1970s because
people
thought that policy makers wouldn't
bring it to an end
and inflation expectations became
embedded in the american psyche that
isn't happening now and the federal
reserve wouldn't permit that to happen
oh so the federal reserve will step in
and help us so
why aren't they tapering faster
by the way i have let me tell you i have
complete trust in the federal reserve
you know why because janet yellen used
to run it
i i have complete trust that an
institution that is so fungible at the
head of the federal reserve which is
supposed to be independent of the
president's policy
moves right over to the treasury
department and is promoting exactly the
same policy why isn't that magical isn't
that just magical i totally trust our
institutions our institutions are not
broken in any serious way
just just excellent excellent stuff
right there
the wall street journal by the way
points out that uh his economic agenda
joe biden's was not designed for
shortages and inflation greg iprites to
bedrock assumption of american politics
that a strong economy is essential to
winning elections today jobs and wages
are growing rapidly the stock market is
at records the public is upbeat about
jobs and financial prospects
but president biden's approval ratings
are underwater democrats just lost the
governor's race in blue trending
virginia
that's because of an unusual economy
because of shortages inflation daily
disruptions a j biden's agenda was not
designed to address that sort of problem
in some ways it may make it worse yeah
you think
so joe biden is uh he's a disaster area
americans are feeling it in their
pocketbook they're cruising for a
bruising the only thing that might save
them honestly is joe manchin the person
there maligning as the great obstacle to
progress might be the only thing that
saves them so joe manchin came out
yesterday and he said yeah we might want
to write on this bill back better
nonsense we might want to wait on it
according to axios red-hot inflation
data validates the instinct of senator
joe manchin to punt president biden's
buildback better agenda until next year
potentially killing a quick deal on the
1.75 trillion dollar package people
familiar with the matter tell axios
well yeah
that would make some sense so all the
people that democrats are targeting and
yelling at
are the people who may be saving them
from disaster
right now joe biden's best bet is to
move with mansion not to move with the
rest of his caucus he should be pulling
back
instead it's all
all torpedoes fire
because he's got to do something
transformative before the old man falls
off his rocker
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out our newest
podcast morning wire on today's episode
they discuss the backlash matthew
mcconaughey is getting for saying he is
against mandating coveted vaccines for
children that episode is available right
now on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts make sure to tune in
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode inflation hits new
highs kyle rittenhouse takes the stand
and another coveted controversy consumes
the nfl
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire
bye